since Jimmy Kimmel is calling people a  piece of [ __ ] we went back into the  archives Wayne's getting chopped off and  dipped in delicious Tangy hot sauce  home alone do love them hot wings that's  a little much now that was Jimmy Kimmel  obviously uh whatever that is 15 20  years ago or so on The Man Show and I  think it's one of the reasons that he  went so woke because he has to atone for  his sins but it's not like we could find  another video of him basically in  blackface also making fun of a very fat  woman would that be possible  foreign  that's why I start every morning with a  Brisk aerobic workout my workout partner  is my maid Marguerite Jimmy come on when  he finds out who's been posting all this  racist stuff on his Twitter account he  is going to be pissed wait a lot of  blackface with this guy a little too  much so when you're talking about the  piece of [ __ ] Jimmy uh perhaps a mirror  would be in order